foreign
your company became prominent on the
internet with the release of a fake Tom
Cruise video deep Tom Cruise that I
think attracted like a billion views on
Tick Tock and Instagram which leads me
to my first question which is please can
we at Ted have our own Tom Cruise video
please uh you know I thought you might
ask so um a little earlier we we had a
crack maybe we'll have a look let's have
a look
what's up internet
I'm north of the Border a at the Ted
conference it's not short for Theodore
but nobody calls me Thomas so it's cool
it's Tom and Ted
yes uh Canada
seriously though everybody here very
nice very polite
especially the whales
I mean
that
so really at metaphysic we specialize in
creating artificially generated content
that looks and feels exactly like
reality so we take kind of real world
data we train these neural Nets and it
can more accurately than the effects or
CGI really create this content but looks
and feels so natural
um and so that is a great example of the
AI being kind of prompted by the natural
performance of a person and kind of the
face goes on top
and it helps the fact that your
co-founder is um you know he's a pretty
good Tom Cruise impersonation indeed
Miles Fisher is uh the foremost Tom
Cruise but not Tom Cruise
um I think you have another example as
well can we see that one yes absolutely
going kind of Beyond faces now talking
about voice
[Music]
tell us what's happening there so what
you see there is really it is the
singing voice of the lady singing
Spanish
um and aloe black who sings Wake Me Up
the Avicii song that he wrote with
Avicii um we are transporting her voice
across to his face so he doesn't sing in
Spanish and then suddenly we transport
it again
um her voice into his voice so anybody
in the future will be able to speak any
language it'll look Perfectly Natural
and this content is becoming more and
more easy to create and eventually it
will end up with a scale where we will
all be kind of main characters in our
own content on the internet
okay
[Laughter]
before we dig into that just a bit I
mean this what you've shown us
um recorded video there
um rumor has it you can also do this
with live video can that be right yes we
can do it live real time and this is
like really at The Cutting Edge of what
we can do today moving from offline
processing to we're processing it so
fast that you can do it in real time and
so well I'm going to challenge you and
your team to do a bit of a first yeah I
mean there's video of you right up on
that screen show us something surprising
you couldn't oh my gosh so wait so there
we go this is um you know a live
real-time model of Chris
um on top of me
um running in real time
and next you'll tell me that it can
oh Lord
I'm so uncomfortable with this
I am so uncomfortable Can it can it do
voice as well
um um we think they can we're we're
really pushing we're really pushing a
limit said AI technology now and I'm
talking exactly as I've heard
Scrambler is coming out is the one in
Italian for sensing I am I am I'm deeply
sorry everyone
subject to you to this you know that
there's something
possibly even worse so to come clean on
this they made me you know I did some
they took some shots of me a couple
weeks ago doing different facial
expressions that they captured a video
model and it turns out I discovered this
week that they can apply that not just
to Tom but to anyone
um and um so my my dear friend Sonny
Bates is here in the front row Sunny do
you consent to uh to channel inner me
for a minute well let's can we try that
I'm really worried about this
do we have sunny on screen
oh this they're Sunny oh no oh no oh no
[Laughter]
I
you know Chris you look amazing all
right enough of that cut that cut that
cut that right now I mean yes more Sunny
more of this Tom Tom Sunny Bates is the
woman who introduced me to Ted without
Sonny Bates none of us would actually be
here now and we do we reward her with
this I mean and now you've finally
become the master you know oh so look
okay amazing
um
it obviously occurs to everyone in this
room that there are some things that can
go horribly wrong with this
um and you know we've already seen you
know examples online of you know what
we've had photographs of trump being
arrested that were unreal there could be
video of it
um there's pornography that can use the
faces of celebrity all these things that
we've seen Deepak how how do you feel
about the downside of this technology so
personally you know we build this stuff
and I'm worried right worried is the
right Instinct for everybody to have and
then you know beyond that think about
you know what can we do to prepare
ourselves how can we try to impact the
future as it spirals in this direction
where as individuals it's going to be
kind of difficult to understand what's
computer generated and what's real and
so there are things that we can do there
raising public awareness of manipulated
media that's one that's you know this is
a great forum for that
will you claim to me that
if you were to shut down your company
right now it wouldn't stop the problem
of deep fake videos because the
Technologies out there that that's going
to happen anyway that that's not within
your control yes there are we're talking
about content that is so compelling if
you know we put any of ourselves inside
content and maybe it is talking to our
loved ones or just talking to our
friends on the beach and it's so
realistic that it looks real it's so
compelling everybody is trying to create
this content today all of the gpus in
the universe are driving it trying to
create this so it doesn't matter what
any one person does this will happen and
it's happening very very quickly
so I mean we'll talk about the upside in
a second but the but it seems like
we are going to have to get used to a
world
where we and our children will no longer
be able to trust the evidence of our
eyes
I think so
um we're going to have to understand a
new set of Institutions to verify what
is authentic media but then we can begin
to lead into some of the creative things
that happen from it and there are
benefits that come with that too so
it'll be an accommodation so talk a bit
about the uh the the benefits I mean
obviously on the entertainment side
there's an amazing number of
possibilities you have Tom Cruise we can
have impossible mission 273 in the year
21.50 right like he will be with us
forever we're working on number 75 000
one net right now yeah
I guess that I guess that is kind of
amazing like we love we've we love
lots of people in the world and we want
the possibility that with their
permission we can do more with them talk
about some other possible upsides what
we've seen in kind of building this
content and watching people interact
with it especially if they're kind of
interacting with themselves maybe it's
their younger 20 year old self or maybe
they're interacting with their partner
but the young version of their partner
there's this tremendous emotional
connection that comes from the very very
photorealistic Beyond The Uncanny kind
of content and so if we can start
deploying that
um among regular people if we can scale
it up so that it works for any kind of
person then we can begin to kind of you
know have more interesting meaningful
human kind of interactions and
relationships online and since the
pandemic we all spend more time online
but it's chat and it's email if we could
get more human emotion more feeling
there's a lot that we can do with that
right and so you know education is a
good example we could have an inspiring
teacher in thousands of classrooms
around the world speaking every language
in the world at the same time and
students could interact with each other
in a way that was you know goes beyond
Zoom there can be real cultural exchange
real socialization
there's a lot that we can do
Beyond you so that teacher example is is
powerful to me like like the fact that a
single teacher could turn a written
lesson into video in any number of
languages and extend indefinitely that
seems like a real amplification of
potentially of good you know human
intent
um I'm excited by that I still don't get
the family side of it like that like if
you want to have a human connection with
someone in your family isn't it like how
won't people just be creeped out by oh
my God I was just looking at your avatar
I thought I thought it was you you know
like how do we get isn't that just
creepy I I think this is definitely a
creepy element to this right and then
you go beyond that and the creepiness
drops away and the medium drops away and
it's the content and the connection
that's there so you know I imagine that
you know if I collect data from my
grandparents who are very old today then
in the future I'll be able to relive
experiences with them and communicate
with them and that it's not going to be
any good for them right they're probably
going to have passed on but for me it'll
help me process who I am my relationship
with them that idea of kind of
decoupling Human Experience both from
where it happens and the moment in time
that it happens I think that we can
create these experiences through hyper
real photorealistic media that allow us
to share the best of our experiences the
best of who we are I'm going to be very
curious to see who's who can feel that
right now my guess is that there's going
to have to be lots of experiments and a
lot of things are going to creep us out
and maybe we'll find some things that
are just absolutely incredible but I
have an important question for you which
is how the hell do I control me now hour
like you've got me on video what's to
stop my me being misused across the
internet now that's right I think that
as we kind of allow companies to create
these realistic experiences as
individuals we need to be empowered to
own our real world data the data used to
train the algorithms and we need to
control how our photorealistic avatars
are created and where they're used so to
this extent I was looking at kind of
conventional current legal institutions
to see what we could do to create new
rights so I created a photorealistic
avatar of myself submitted it to the US
copyright office to see if they would
register my copyright in it and this is
what the video looked like
here is the AI realistic version of
myself
even if the appearance of this AI
representation of myself may change
cosmetically or if I change my hair or
add creative features my intention is to
create this AI version of myself that
embodies the essence of who I am as a
person under any circumstance
wow
so I think you have shown us what is
going to be a repeated theme in this
conference which is the future is going
to be
weird and wonderful at the same time
quite what the balance is between those
two TBD but this is a world where each
of us is going to have to think
differently about who we are and claim
these rights what you're saying is that
if people have this right you can
picture a world where for example if a
video goes viral on YouTube without your
consent you'll be able to take it down
because of some link back to this that's
right I think the most important thing
that we can do when we're talking about
data from a real world being able to
power these things is that we need to
own property rights over the data we
shouldn't sign it over to companies
through terms of service we shouldn't
give it away if you fundamentally own it
then you can be in control and you're at
the ground level of all of the economies
and all of the use cases that are going
to spin up through history
it's a lot but uh we're on the way now
Tom Graham thank you so much for sharing
this technology thank you very much
and sunny Bates I'm so sorry thank you
so much